how do you know if a duck because we
talk about mental health in this but how
do you know if your dog is suffering
from depression or anxiety what signs
are there yeah they're they're signs are
you know lack of appetite uh not
enjoying the things he used to enjoy uh
being more fatigued than normal changing
personality uh uh hiding walking away
from you I just this segment recently on
is it possible dogs can suffer from the
blues and they can but also you have to
remember Michael this is so so true
having trained over 40 000 animals I'm
telling you from the bottom of my heart
that animals take on the way we feel so
if I'm working with a person that's a
depressed person generally I'm going to
have a dog that may be a little
depressed if I'm working with a hyper
crazy
we talked about some of my famous
clients Rodney Dangerfield
guy was a maniac dog was a maniac
I'm just telling you the way it was what
did you tell me you said that you you
you came up and he was just like out of
a movie he answers his door and he's
like hey Warren you got to help me he's
in a row my my dog jumps on my leg with
his eyes closed no respect Lauren in a
robe that I went where if I was a Hermit
living in Montana that's how so he was
talking about this little dog and the
poodle man I think it was named Nico I
don't remember now anyway he was just
it's exactly that and he said the
greatest line I told you ever heard was
Warren
talk about no respect the dog humps my
leg but before he does he closes his
eyes that was just and then going to his
car he would invite me and fade all his
concerts hey Cajun cast I'm sure
painting cash of course he had he had
Dangerfield me a favor would be regulus
if Dangerfield's glove we would go there
but you could not go backstage at a
Dangerfield concert and not be stoned by
the time you walk down I'm not saying he
was smoking but just everybody else
everybody else was oh yeah I would never
say you but everyone everyone else great
time